all right joining us now Florida
Republican senator Rick Scott welcome
back to Fox News Sunday all right you
heard uh the explanation there from your
colleague uh Senator Langford who by all
accounts is a well-respected person on
Capitol Hill and within the Senate he
talks about just the last few months the
terror watch people that have come
through the Special Interest aliens and
it comes on the back of this letter from
a number of former FBI Executives
warning Congressional leaders saying
this it would be difficult to overstate
the danger represented by the presence
inside our border of of what is
comparatively a multi-division army of
young single adult males from hostile
Nations the country has been invaded an
invasion that will continue as long as
the nation's enemies perceive it will be
tolerated so do you agree with that
assessment by the way and if so why not
take something that would stop some of
the traffic sooner rather than
later well first I think James is he's
smart he's hardworking he knows the
issue he's on a suicide mission um the
Democrat do not want to secure the
Border I'm a business guy never did a
business deal where the other side did
not want have the same goal I have
Democrats don't want to secure the
Border that's number one number two is
right now this border could be secure
but we know we have a lawless
Administration completely Lawless Biden
Administration so the only way this is
going to happen is if we have
accountability that forces Biden to
enforce the law we can change all these
laws there's laws now Trump secured the
Border Biden decided to open the border
and the exact same laws we don't need a
new bill we need something to enforce to
force Biden to comply with the law now
James James is doing the best he can to
try to explain the bill that
unfortunately I don't know why they
don't share with this I mean I I'd
rather be Force something but we don't
get anything but what we do know Biden's
Lawless he doesn't want to secure the
Border Biden's don't B the Democrats
don't want to secure the border and
McConnell has told Langford that he
cannot put accountability in measures in
there to require Biden to secure the
Border today he said that will not
happen so what about the issue though if
if you have this rolling number that
when you hit 5,000 which is going to
happen very quickly at this border it
would be mandatory that the Border
closes down is that not some measure of
accountability that it would at least
stop the flow temporarily until maybe
you have a re-election or a different
president well Biden could do that today
why does he do it today I mean he
doesn't need any of this to secure the
Border Trump secured the border with the
exact same laws I mean there unless
there's some accountability measure that
forces Biden to secure the Border tied
to Ukraine a tied to something else
unless there's something like that
Biden's not going to comply with the law
if it was important for him to comply
with the law he would do it right now if
we if we can't force Biden to to secure
the Border we need to shut the border
today I can tell you everybody in
Florida I mean we love immigration legal
immigration we don't want drugs we don't
want human traffickers we don't want
criminals we don't want terrorists it
needs to be done today and the only way
that's going to happen is we get a bill
that forces Biden to do it and there's
and we've we've been told McConnell will
not allow um James Li first to putting
that the bill it's not in the bill so I
mean I what you've done negotiations
before so you know what this is like
that until that deal is done this is a
lot of tenuous back and forth so
hopefully you'll see the text we all
will very soon but I want to ask you
about the ACC acction that you guys
actually don't want to get a bill done
Washington Post says this Democrats are
offering something Republicans have
wanted for years but dear leader Trump
says no and suddenly GOP senators are
afraid to say yes how much of your
objection is based primarily on the
former president's objection to this
bill that he hasn't seen
either he's irrelevant to this
conversation he's not in office all
right and by the way I talked to
president Trump he's never asked me uh
to be oppose something but you know what
the American voters are in the same
position Trump's in and same position
I'm in we need to secure the Border
today and the only way you can do that
with a lawless Administration is you
have to make them do it you have to have
tie it to something and what not what I
don't get is Mitch McConnell doesn't
want to do that it's the most important
thing we want out of this bill and we
and and by the way we got to be very
careful we don't codify Biden's open
policies and we don't hamstring Trump
when he wins the president
but this is if you if you don't if if
you don't want to secure the Border
today don't be blamed it on on Trump you
know say you you don't care what the
voters think it's not it's not all what
Trump thinks it's the voters want a
secure border today okay I before you go
I want to ask you about a case that you
have some involvement with this is a
government contractor who worked to get
IRS records and leak them including for
president Trump and thousands of other
people you have said in a letter to the
attorney general you were impacted by
this too and you don't think the do J is
taking this seriously enough Wall Street
Journal says about this this man's going
to be sentenced tomorrow that Mr Little
John doesn't dispute that he stole tax
records he gave the files to the New
York Times and Progressive website prop
publica Mr Little John's lawyers say he
decided quote the American public had a
right to know the president's tax
information will you be at that
sentencing tomorrow what would you like
to
see I'm I'm going to be there I he
released my tax return He intentionally
took the job to release Trump's tax
return
and this he's he did over 7,500 people
and he's going to be he's going to plead
guilty to one case I mean this is just
this is an example of the justice
department deciding oh if you do
something against Republicans who cares
if you do it against Democrats that's
bad but if you do it against Republicans
oh we'll just give you a slap on the
wrist we will follow that case Senator
Scott thanks for your time hi everyone
I'm Brian kilme I want you do me a favor
I want you to click to subscribe to the
Fox News YouTube page this is the only
way that I know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on Fox you can get it
all here on YouTube so subscribe right
now